[Música]
[Aplausos]
depois de tanta criatividade e
maravilhosas criaturas que passam por
aqui aparece um velho no fim da manhã
espero que tenham paciência vamos
escutar quando cheguei a lugares como
este eu fico sempre uma posição bem
difícil
perguntou mall e trouxe a sua
apresentação assim não o seu power point
não tenho como não tá então a gente tem
mas não tem onde quer que nos vai dizer
não sei ainda ninguém me perguntou nada
como eu sei que então aqui ninguém
perguntou se eu tinha a bordo põe
ninguém perguntou nem me deixa eu
perguntar e eu imagino as perguntas
poste mais nessa nossa casa então eu
quero partilhar com vocês durante este
descanso minutos
algumas aprendizagens algumas dúvidas
ignorâncias a primeira das quais têm a
ver com um episódio há 50 anos quando
este já é um jovem professor que eu fui
se uma escolinha e encontrou uma turma
chamada do lixo lixo chamavam lixo e
seres humanos eram todos jovens com 15
anos na primeira série
a primeira série todo o tempo que estava
na 1ª série
eu tinham reprovado sete vezes o que não
sabiam ler eu perguntei por que não
sabem ler e eles disseram olha a
professora cozinha todos os anos vem uma
professora novamente tenta ensinar como
ela faz o ensino sul a eo papel pipal
é que tal tua gente junta pato
alberto pinto importa o quanto o pp uma
empresa e senti um calafrio
era assim que eu ensinava ver a parar
se eu continuasse ensiná-los a lei 10
módulos 1 e eu girei aprender a ler
o primeiro sentimento que este foi o
sentimento profissional a minha cultura
medo quando a gente vai cair pressão vai
por uma das duas razões
ou por amor ou por vingança eu tinha ido
por vingança
sinceramente eu tinha ido por vingança
porque eu jurei a mim mesmo que nenhum
aluno eu passaria por situações desde
usam que eu passei por mexer num cortiço
enfim ser pobre histórico bill e bom na
verdade é que eu não conseguir vingar o
modo como eu ensinava um método fônico
ou a opa não ensinava
ou seja eu ligava o direito à educação
então é possível que eu estava possuído
por uma síndrome síndrome do pânico
então fui ver porque é que se ensina
deste modo qualquer professor já fez
isso
descobri descobri ao mesmo tempo que
descobrir a origem de uma das duas
palavras que estão na bandeira do brasil
a ordem é que esta escola que nós temos
ela teve origem na prússia militar do
século 19
a escola está a militarizada
mas aí o pessoal é incompatível com a
aprendizagem com aprendizagem playing
posição
então o que eu precisava era de
desmilitarizar na e desmilitarizar a
escola em outro problema a resolver a
questão porque continua a ensinar os
imóveis não sou ético eu sei que nos
ensino impondo um currículo impondo a
aula impondo a turma impondo e não vou
conseguir
então percebi que o professor não tem um
nome
solitário o ato de aprender e de ensinar
um ato solidário e nos juntar com outras
surgiu o problema é que eu estava na
escola da ponte há 43 anos
o sentimento comum é um sentimento
egoísmo aquela comunidade vivia no
sentimento egoísmo enorme
corrupção competitividade negativa
aí eu perceber porque é que é escola é
como é a segunda origem da escola tem a
ver com origem na inglaterra do século
19 da primeira revolução industrial
a escola está policiada é jaula de aula
e nós tivemos que fazer desaparecer
essa aula de aula não dá
estamos a trabalhar em equipa e
entregamos a escola à comunidade
passando do centro professor para o
centro no aluno no protagonismo juvenil
e cada um de nós agir assim mas como a
síndrome tremenda também que era a
síndrome de vira lata porque tudo que
nós introduzimos como prato que vinha do
estrangeiro é como o brasil tem casa em
tudo que precisa mas vai para os estados
unidos procuraram o que têm cá dentro ou
a finlândia que não serve pra nada
enfim é verdade
então nós começamos a perceber que não
poderíamos fazer isso em portugal e no
brasil também não
quando eu vim para o brasil eu
compreendi que teria de compra de de
entender o que é o brasil
armadores e eu encontrei educadores
lauro de oliveira lima nise da silveira
milton santos hora está fernando
eurípedes barsanulfo anísio teixeira
darcy ribeiro fernando azevedo paulo
ferreira é hilário aprendizagem o
paradigma da aprendizagem não resolve
totalmente o problema da escola seria
bom foi passado doou do professor o
aluno passando para mim uma instrução
paradigma da aprendizagem não era
suficiente porque havia um outro um
outro sentimento um terceiro sentimento
que estava na sociedade brasileira
o sentimento óleo a cultura do óleo
então nós percebemos que a bandeira
brasileira está incompleta
falta uma palavra quando no final do
século 19
o benjamim constant militar cria um
primeiro currículo escolar
eu era um positivista e portanto colocou
no currículo e na escola que foi criada
as três palavras que augusto conta
definiu como sendo as palavras básicas o
positivismo e todos os militares
floriano e toda mas eram positivistas
isso o lema do continente é este o amor
por princípio a ordem por base o
progresso por finalidade
eu pergunto porque é que só está a
palavra amor na bandeira do brasil e fui
procurar outra origem da escola
esta escola nós temos para além de ter
origem na proximidade
isso é preciso de militarizar lá pra mim
ter origem nas prisões em inglaterra da
primeira revolução industrial e se é
preciso sentar ao lado
esta escola tem origem também nos
conventos do século 19 da frança
a célula de aula a monja sozinha a tia
então é preciso usar tirar da clausura
como introduzindo a palavra fábio básica
que vai encontrar o ódio o amor que tem
de voltar a bandeira brasileira
por que aconteceu aconteceu
vou pensar assim porque estava numa
escola brasileira vieram ter comigo
o psol no estanto eu li porque o michael
estava terem toda a gente a segunda
feira eu quando vai na sexta vai mais ou
menos mas depois do fim de semana está
pior do eu fui correndo me que eu estava
a tentar bater nem toda a gente ganhou
eu costumo mandar protocolados em uma
cabeçada que nos óculos ou pular
virei pra mim podia toda a gente vocês
além de centenas no chão com ela eu
temia eu achei estranho
cheiro nauseabundo ali e vou explicar
por que o michael quando fez 5 anos
estava no barraco da favela e chegaram
os policiais com fuzil ea mãe defrontou
os com uma pistola foi morta que caiu
sobre eu e ainda furou uma vala tem sua
mãe fura olho um pulmão e foi para o
hospital e enfim depois quando você o
hospital uma vizinha acolheu mas o
companheiro da vizinha chegou evaporou
independência bateu contra um muro eu
tenho oito meses e não em coma com
seqüelas terríveis e depois depois e
depois eu sou que eu hein jovem 56 anos
tenha sido estuprado várias vezes por
vários homens de moto quando eu sinner
vavá serão voltava os internautas abria
eu estava sentado na minha frente
sentada em boston tremendo de frio
soando ser humano não estava ninguém
olhou pra mim e eu posso eu gritando que
eu me ajuda tinham me ajudem chama do
lado mas afasta-se está nas mãos de novo
e foi quando o tio também chorou
onde não há vínculo amoroso não
aprendizagem
eu encontrei com ela o vento
[Aplausos]
eu encontrei com o um vínculo amoroso
o vínculo de pessoa para pessoa por
escolas são pessoas escolas não são pré
deus escolas são pessoas e as pessoas
são os seus valores e o valor
fundamental à sobrevivência humana é o
amor ninguém vir sozinho eu existe
porque existe a minha liberdade não
termina onde começa a liberdade a minha
liberdade começa onde começa a tua
liberdade e isto nós frisa não têm
direitos e foi isso que estou falando
brasil fraterno
estou a falar de uma escola humanizada
estou a falar de uma escola que não tem
aula não tem turma não tem cérebro não
tem prova não tem nada da tragédia o
século 19
acho que é difícil criar obstáculos são
imensos e temos uma terceira síndrome
a síndrome da gabriela eu nasci assim eu
fui sempre assim a família a sociedade
pensa que tudo tem sempre no fundo no
século 19
nós temos que entender que a sociedade
tem todo o direito de pensar assim
então amigos para que nós precisamos que
temos de modificar a escola porque a
escola não mudar a sociedade e é o nosso
paulo freire das pessoas e as pessoas
mudam a sociedade então faz um convite
para se juntarem tantos brasileiros
também aqui em fortaleza questão já
criando novas construções sociais de
aprendizagem onde efetivamente
aprendemos uns com os outros meios
utilizados pelo mundo onde efetivamente
aprendizagem acontece na inter subject
virada quando sabemos que aquilo que
estudamos tem sentido e vamos criar
significado e que é significado não seja
conhecimento para competir com o outro
mas para partilhar com todos na
perspectiva de uma sociedade fraterna e
sustentável
então vou poder ver os convidados para
nos acompanhar estamos muito já estou a
viver agora no distrito federal
e o secretário de educação estadual é
meu amigo um homem bom
ele pediu ajuda então nós vamos mudar o
distrito federal todos da equipe quatro
anos uma aula nem a turminha nada dessa
porcaria desculpa que são incomoda
vai haver gente que vai aprender o
direito da pessoa mas ser uma realidade
os professores vão ser bem pagos vão ser
bem cuidados e não xingados normal
tranquilo
mas para isso dado que estou a fazer é
uma aula e não perguntei dadá chegou o
momento vamos passar a tarefa para casa
há mais ou menos uns dois mil e tal anos
um senhor chamado amistosos
escreveu vários tratados sobre o reino
animal em um dos tratados sobre animais
que vivem com os homens escreveu a mosca
doméstica possui oito patas
durante séculos e por toda a idade média
a influência da lista o suficiente e os
monges copistas passavam da papiro em
papiro de papel em papel é verdade
aristotélica a mosca doméstica possui
oito patas
a mosca doméstica possui nenhum
questionava longe talvez animado pelo
espírito científico parou e foi procurar
uma mosca tosca com duas patas e ele
isso deve estar amputada
foi a segunda apareceu a mosca viu ao
fim de três ou quatro músicas voltou
para a mesa de conquista escreveu a
mosca doméstica possui seis patas
então digamos que nós temos que descolou
nizar a nossa mente
nós teremos de repensar tudo isso o que
a escola que temos e provocam genocídio
educacional temendo milhões de
analfabetos milhões de baht deles
professores doentes insuficiência
miserável suicídio solidão e passarmos
realmente fazer uma tarefa de casa que
eu vou deixar inspirado nesta metáfora
do status se realmente aquela pista ou
só vou pensar com a sua cabeça e usou
pensar também no benefício do outro
porque eles tocam os dominado
praticamente toda a ciência da idade
média
então nós fazer um pouquinho como
galileu posso fazer um pouquinho como o
pânico
vamos para casa agora quando for embora
a contar para as moscas tarefa para casa
tá bom ficar em paz tchau
[Aplausos]